a concept is the essence of your design
the driver behind all of your design
moves
and it's your entire project distilled
into a single idea
today i'm going to show you the process
for developing the concept for
a library renovation that we're
currently working on in my office
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i
am a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver vc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and
also some tools and strategies that can
help us have more meaningful and
fulfilling careers
in architecture all right so let's get
to the fun part in architecture
school there's a very big focus on just
the
development of your concept the concept
itself
and so your project might be a building
but it could also be an art piece or a
piece of furniture
as long as it helps reinforce your
concept
but when you're working on real projects
the concept itself is of course very
important but
the importance actually comes from its
use
and the fact that it's really a design
tool
for all the millions of decisions you
have to make on any single project
it's also great for communicating why
you're doing something to your clients
and to your consultants it's also great
for providing
an objective reference point you kind of
have to remember that
design is by nature subjective and so
when you're working in a team
you you might develop an idea but you
have to make sure that everyone on the
team
is on board with the direction before
you move on
sometimes when we have design reviews
we'll have instances where like every
single person in the room will have
their own opinions on the design
so in situations like this it's
really helpful to look back at the
concept and say
you know this approach makes sense
because
it reinforces the concept this way
rather than saying like
uh well i think this looks better in
this video i'm going to show you the
process for
developing the concept itself and in the
next video i'm going to show you
how to use that concept to develop the
design
so this particular project is a interior
renovation
for library so not only are you taking
aspects of the site
and the program to develop your concept
you're also taking
aspects of the existing building if the
existing building is
really interesting that can form a
really big part of your building's
concept
i personally like having more
constraints to work with
because the more constraints you have
the more
objective reasons you can give to why
you've designed something in a certain
way unfortunately i can't
show you any drawings or actual
renderings of the space
because it is still confidential at the
moment so
i'll just have to show you guys in
abstraction
through sketches but i'm i'm really
really
excited to show you guys photographs
probably in the next couple of months
so the project is the renovation of an
existing library
and libraries are going through a huge
transformation right now
with the digitization of books they're
becoming
more than just a place for books it's
actually becoming a community hub
where they have tons of events and
workshops
and lots of tools for people to come and
learn new skills
so for this project the librarians
wanted to take
a chunk of the space which is used to
store books
and they wanted to turn it into public
spaces like a digital media space
and a lounge and a multi-purpose room
the library has this grand
entrance this uh three-story atrium when
you walk in
and we will be blowing out this entire
area
and turning it into more public space
we're also renovating other areas like
this
info center and in the next phase of the
project we're also putting in a new
children's library
a new teens library and a heller upstair
that connects the two different levels
the first step to any design process is
gathering and analyzing all of the data
on your project so usually you can
divide the research into three
categories
the client or the design brief the site
and the building typology the client
usually includes
information about the client and the
building requirements
the accommodation the construction
budget and the site
will have information about uh the
neighborhood
or the climate the orientation views
access
context history use etc etc and the
building typology
is of course the type and use um and in
our case it's the library
so the client for us was the city of
who is paying for the project but the
librarians
are actually our real clients they're
the ones using the space and they're the
ones who know
what works and what doesn't work so the
very first step
of every design process is
not developing the concept and it's
not even trying to understand what the
client wants it's actually
helping the client discover and
understand
what they want you like cheesecake
i don't like cheesecake you like
cheesecake oh i guess i do like
cheesecake have you ever seen star wars
what obi-wan kenobi is talking just
imperial guards and just making that
repeating this sentence
all the time these aren't the droids
you're looking for
these aren't the droids we're looking
for he can go about his business
have you ever seen that you're seeing
star wars
usually you need to come in as the
expert
and inform them on the best practices
of that particular building typology for
us
a lot of that was collecting a bunch of
precedents
from our last project and from projects
from other firms
and also giving them a sense of where
libraries are headed in the future
and what kind of programs can kind of
future proof
the library i think libraries are one of
the most
interesting typologies i'm probably a
little bit biased because
i did do my master's thesis on libraries
and library renovations
but it's a typology that's a direct
reflection
of society's relationship with
information
and knowledge for example during the
dark ages
libraries were just repositories for
books the books
would literally be chained to the desks
it would only be accessible to a few
people who could read
and now there's less focus on
physical books and there is more focus
on the services
and the real social interactions they're
providing big
open spaces rather than small reading
nooks if you're
interested in libraries i would highly
highly recommend the book
library at night it's just a beautifully
written book on the history and the
meaning
behind libraries i'll leave the link in
the description below
and i also think librarians are some of
the most
interesting people and like the best
clients they're very organized they're
very articulated
and they would consolidate and gather
the comments
and we get proper timely feedback
all typed up in a word document
during this process we held discovery
sessions where we
try to get as much input as possible
from the librarians
on how they envisioned the space we
heard things like they want a flexible
and adaptable space accessible and
inclusive for everyone a space that
inspires
to create a space to collaborate a space
for
intergenerational connections a space
that accommodates
the different user activities flexible
spaces
and a space that celebrates the
diversity of the community the library
is located in a neighborhood where
the population is 62 immigrants
with only 45 percent of the residents
actually speaking english at home
the other thing we notice is that the
buildings
located in a very very dense area
it's an area that's being heavily
developed right now
and the library kind of sits in the
midst of all these super
tall skyscrapers the library has a
massive garden so this building
gives a bit of a breathing space to this
super dense area and it becomes a little
garden in this concrete jungle at the
scale of the building
this also reflects the nature of the
library
we have all of these super dense
programs
and we also have this tall three-story
atrium
that has this solid void relationship so
one of the strategies that i like to use
in coming up with the concept
is looking at the information and trying
to relate
aspects of it back to a
original source
it's a little tricky because there's no
hard definition
of an original source because everything
is kind of built on each other
but a good original source are icons
or visuals that are recognizable across
different cultures
when we're talking about architecture
specifically anything that's become
widespread enough to become a kind of
typology
could be considered an original source i
looked at this strong solid void
relationship
and the first thing that came to my mind
was a cave
[Music]
there's a lot of interesting material
tones that we could
pull from this but i i scrapped this
idea
pretty quickly because it didn't really
work at a programmatic or functional
level
so going back to the analysis they also
kept talking about their desire
to build a community hub and to bring
indigenous identity
into the space and so i thought of the
native longhouse
which is a traditional typology and
it's usually the heart of indigenous
communities
they would hold religious ceremonies and
have
community gatherings and this is also
where
they have the fire pit and this kind of
gives it
the opening at the roof which is
somewhat similar to our condition i
think
there's a interesting programmatic
connection
but i just felt like there weren't
enough architectural elements i could
pull from this concept to develop a
rich material palette
and so i thought about what about a
community living room
this is a key phrase they kept talking
about
is there anything i could pull from the
typology of living rooms
and so i thought about bringing in some
of these more
domestic elements like carpets and
cushions and area rugs
but in this case i felt like there
wasn't enough consistency
in the type for it to become a strong
concept
then i went for a walk and sat in this
little courtyard
and spent some time pondering my life
choices
what if we included a fountain feature
in the atrium space
it could be like an outdoor courtyard
the librarians were really adamant about
bringing
nature into the space how feasible would
that be
in this case the atrium and the site
both had the solid void relationship
both a void within a solid
a donut
the courtyard is a design trend that is
universal across different cultures and
throughout history
and it's a design element that hasn't
really gone out of style
while a lot of design trends have come
and gone based on
changes in living styles
they were originally conceived to
control the microclimatic conditions
within buildings
but their functions have evolved over
time being used for
social activities like cooking washing
sleeping gathering or socializing
this seemed to fit perfectly with the
atrium of the library
which is a space that connects a lot of
these different distinct functions
together
and serves as the main circulation
corridor
the courtyard works on a programmatic
level
it works on a physical level it works on
a contextual level
and at a material level it's it
it creates an interesting material
palette and it will
fit into all of the different areas and
elements of the project
so this is one of the strategies that i
use to develop
a concept and of course the
process looks pretty different based on
the project because each project
is unique one thing that is consistent
throughout all the design phases and
all projects is how much we look for
inspiration
from other sources you know i used to
think that good ideas come from deep
inside your head because i didn't want
to
accidentally copy something that i'd
seen on the internet
but you know what there's no original
creations
everything is basically a different
iteration of another thing
when you think of the romantic image of
an architect
you think of them drawing day and night
on their drafting board
coming up with these crazy brilliant
ideas
but in reality a huge chunk of our time
is actually spent looking at books
magazines
and the internet for inspiration the
internet if you know how to use it
properly
is really like the best place
for creating connections and
serendipitous connections
anyways i hope that was interesting for
you guys i
presented this concept to the team and
to the client and
they were on board so in the next video
i'm going to talk about how you can
translate some of these concepts
into the design and how you can use this
to drive every little decision in your
project
if you enjoyed this video please give me
a thumbs up and
let me know if you have any questions
and let me know if you have
any other strategies that you like to
use for developing concepts
bye see in the next video
you